what is going on everybody welcome back
to the channel I'm your host Warren
Thompson and it does look like Marvel
Studios is indeed going to be shaking
things up a little bit with Disney plus
and their Disney plus content if you
have not heard Disney has fired their
old CEO Bob chapek and they have brought
back their old CEO before him Bob Iger
now most people think that this is an
incredibly good thing Bob Iger did an
incredible job as CEO over his years and
during that time Marvel Studios was
great now keep in mind I'm specifically
going to be talking about Marvel Studios
in this video not Disney as a whole but
during that time Marvel Studios really
was great the content was great but then
came 2020 where Bob chapek became CEO of
Disney and unfortunately the pandemic
happened as well but they did release
Disney plus during this time however it
seems like the board of directors were
not happy with how he handled everything
and today we have some news that makes
it seem like Marvel Studios might
actually go back to making fewer
projects a year which I think can
actually be a really good thing the only
question is how much will it actually
affect Phase 5 phase six and what they
have planned beyond that also and we'll
talk about this in this video Marvel
Studios could be preparing for a big
announcement soon whether that's
revealing projects they haven't revealed
yet or maybe even telling us that some
things might be delayed it looks like
they are going to be making that
announcement soon we'll talk about all
of this in this video and a big reminder
to subscribe to the channel if you are a
big Marvel and pop culture fan were
almost to 1 million now what we talked
about in the past before and just the
other day is that maybe Bob chapek with
Disney plus coming out had some sort of
a quota for Marvel Studios to hit a lot
of the Marvel fans have talked about how
Marvel seems to be doing a lot of shows
a year a lot of different projects we
went from two maybe three movies a year
to now four movies a year and six plus
projects a year that is a lot and I
think everybody can admit that sometimes
the quality does lack now don't get me
wrong I can still enjoy something that
the quality of say the CGI isn't all the
way there but some of the storytelling
and some of the writing I think has been
just a little bit off now we have heard
some reports that Marvel Studios has
been working their employees very hard
and perhaps overworking them but that is
because they have so many projects
coming out well like I said that might
actually be changing thanks to a new
report today according to an article by
The Hollywood Reporter they state that
the head of media and entertainment
distribution Kareem Daniel is set to
leave the company as well with former
CEO Bob Iger returning now this doesn't
really come as a big surprise because
when Bob Iger returned he did say he
would be implementing organizational and
operating changes within the company
over the next few weeks but what's
really interesting about this news is
that Kareem Daniel and Bob chapac were
really focused on growing Disney plus
growing the number of subscriptions for
the streaming services growing the
number of views for their shows to set
satisfy the board of directors and the
investors so what this means was they
were most likely having Marvel Studios
pump out a lot of content as we've seen
however Bob Iger before he left and
before Bob chapac came in was always
more focused on the creative side so we
essentially went from Marvel being
focused on creative things creative
movies and maybe creative ideas for
shows since they knew Disney plus was
coming to essentially the CEO of Disney
telling everybody they need to make a
lot of content now this can be very
problematic because if you're forced to
make a lot of content creativity can
sometimes go away you kind of have to
sacrifice creativity for time which is
why some fans may think that the Disney
plus projects may have lacked and even
the movies can suffer as well because
obviously Marvel Studios has to cover
movies and shows now but perhaps we are
about to experience a change and like I
mentioned before perhaps some things
could even be getting delayed and pushed
back and hopefully not but maybe some
things even completely removed from the
Slate Bob iger's return is simply to fix
pretty much everything Bob chapek did
over the past couple of years this will
most likely result in a shift back to a
creative Focus which can be a really
really good thing for Marvel Studios
this could have them focusing more on
the creative side and the quality side
of things again rather than having to
bust out six or more Disney plus
projects a year now don't get me wrong I
do enjoy the Disney Plus shows and I'm
actually a pretty big fan of the Disney
plus special presentations I do however
think that they were doing too much and
I think that Bob Iger thinks the same so
what could this mean for Phase 5 and
phase six well it means that some things
could be shifted but things might also
be canceled this is a little bit
concerning but I do think that phase
five is kind of safe right now mostly
because what they've done for phase five
all of the projects are pretty important
leading up to phase six and Secret Wars
however there is one project that might
be in Jeopardy and that is blade only
because it's had a lot of problems
recently however they did just find a
new team for it so maybe things are back
on track but as far as Phase 5 goes
Ant-Man and The Wasp quantumania that's
not going anywhere secret invasion is
going to be very important so I think
that's the input of course Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 that's gonna stay put
as well Echo could be in Jeopardy but
I'm going to say no because we are going
to have Daredevil born again and we know
that Kingpin is going to be a big part
of Echo and Daredevil born again so if
they canceled echo or pushed Echo back
that would mean that they would have to
push Daredevil back as well and I don't
think that they want to do that because
they know fans are super excited for
that project plus not to mention
Spider-Man 4 is supposed to tackle some
things that happen in Daredevil born
again and I know they're not gonna push
Spider-Man 4 back they're just not gonna
do that that's a big one for them so I
think Echo and Daredevil are safe now
Loki season 2 that's gonna have a huge
impact on the Kang Dynasty and Avengers
Secret Wars that is safe the Marvels
that's probably safe as well like I
mentioned blade that's kind of iffy an
iron heart might not have a huge impact
so this one could be in Jeopardy
especially after we did just see
ironheart and black panther wakanda
forever however they've already been
filming it so it's probably going to be
safe I think Agatha Covenant chaos is
safe but it actually could be in
Jeopardy of moving I doubt they're going
to cancel it but they could move it and
I don't think they're going to move or
cancel Captain America new world order
or the Thunderbolts if they do they will
simply move them back and they'll kind
of be a part of phase six or they'll
just extend Phase 5 which would
unfortunately mean we would have to wait
longer to get these properties and
longer for the King Dynasty and Secret
Wars now for phase six they only
announced three projects the Fantastic
Four the King Dynasty and Avengers
Secret Wars now there is a project that
we already know about Deadpool 3 which
is supposed to come out on November 8th
of 2024 so that should be the very first
project coming out in phase six however
here's my worry like I mentioned Bob
Iger may come back and tell Marvel
Studios that that he wants more time
focused on each of these projects which
would mean they would have to extend
Phase 5 and extend phase six which would
essentially mean delays pushing things
back which is better than canceling
projects and today it was recently
confirmed by thecosmiccircus.com that
Marvel Studios is going to be attending
ccxp this is a huge convention and
Marvel Studios has been known to drop
some bombs at ccxp now most of the time
it's reveals like a Spider-Man trailer
they typically don't reveal a phase
however since phase six has not been
fully revealed yet they might give us
some release dates however what I'm
really hoping for is they don't announce
delays with this big change coming up
with Disney happening so recently in
this announcement of them attending ccxp
is so recent as well it has been
concerned now I'd like to think that
everything they revealed so far is going
to stay the same but moving forward they
probably will be doing less Disney plus
projects a year maybe even less movies
of course only one less movie but less I
think they might be cutting down to
three four movies a year and maybe four
Disney plus projects a year as well with
maybe one or two special presentations I
think this would be better than what
they are currently doing because they
could focus more on quality and focus
more on things and take their time
because they're not rushed because the
next project is coming up so I think
overall it would be a really good thing
and I think these big changes are coming
to Marvel Studios but let me know your
thoughts about all of this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news for
live updates you can follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
foreign